- [Emma] Cerro Blanco is the
biggest sand dune in the world.
I had no idea people could
ski in a place like this.
Once you're at the top,
you have about 4,000 feet
of vertical drop until
you get to the bottom.
Whoo!
I will remember that moment
for the rest of my life.
- Let's do this!
- [Emma] Whoo!
(chill out music)
My name is Emma Dahlström,
I'm from Sweden,
and I'm a professional free-skier.
- [Jesper] I'm Jesper Tjäder, I'm also
a professional free-skier.
We're both on the Swedish National Team.
Yee-haw!
We travel all over the world to ski.
But we usually go to the mountains
where it's cold and snowy.
- [Emma] When we got to Peru,
we started in a small oasis
called Huacachina.
You would look around and
all you could see is desert.
- [Jesper] I was really nervous
for my first run in the sand
'cause obviously it's not snow.
It felt sticky in the beginning
but when you get some speed
it felt pretty similar to snow, actually.
It felt pretty cool to
ski in shorts and a shirt.
Yeah!
- [Emma] We stayed there
for about three days
and did some rails and jumps.
And then we headed out to Cerra Blanco,
which is basically one
big mountain of just sand.
- [Jesper] Once we were at
the base of Cerra Blanco,
we hiked with all our gear
for about three or four hours.
By the time we got to the
top it was completely dark.
That next morning, when
we first saw the view,
that was magic.
- [Emma] I watched the sun
come out over the mountains
and then we just dropped in.
(cheering)
It was such a crazy feeling,
and I was smiling the whole way down.